powerful cosmic rays smash through
spaceships
but how can objects smaller than an atom
carry enough energy to be dangerous to
astronauts
moving objects carry energy we call this
kinetic energy and when they strike
something they transform that energy
[Applause]
when I hit my hand the kinetic energy of
my fist
transforms into sound and heat in
vibration my hand hurts a little from
that impact from the transformation of
energy
it's the same thing with cosmic rays
when they slam into a human brain cell
or a computer chip they dump some energy
causing damage
how much damage depends on their kinetic
energy and that comes down to two things
mass and speed intuitively
things that are moving at the same speed
if they're more massive they carry more
energy bigger asteroid slamming into
Earth will do more damage than a smaller
asteroid
if you double the mass of an object its
kinetic energy also doubles
although mass is important it's not as
important as speed
speed matters even more than Mass
kinetic energy depends directly on the
mass but it depends on the square of the
speed here's what that means you double
the mass you have double the kinetic
energy you double the speed you have
four times the kinetic energy
when it comes to speed cosmic rays are
the Elite
an ultra high energy cosmic ray detected
in 1991 hit the atmosphere so fast
scientists called it the oh my God
particle
[Music]
thought they would ever ever see until
this fluorescent streak in the Utah Sky
no one believed the particle could reach
the Earth traveling so close to the
speed of light making cosmic ray
particles far more dangerous than
expected as you approach the speed of
light
energy momentum Mass they start to act a
little bit differently Einstein's
equations of Relativity become important
the physics changes and the energy it
has becomes much much much stronger
if a particle is moving at close to the
speed of light that means that its
energy is almost at the maximum allowed
by the laws of physics
it's amazing to think that something as
Tiny as a proton could actually be
dangerous to a human being but amazingly
that proton is moving so fast it carries
as much energy as a baseball thrown at
100 miles an hour a baseball contains
over a trillion trillion protons imagine
all that energy carried by just one
particle so now you get a sense of just
how risky these can be
ultra high energy cosmic rays like the
oh my God Particle are like supersonic
missiles they are the fastest but
they're so rare astronauts are unlikely
to be hit by one
solar cosmic rays or like BB pellets
abundant but our spacecraft can block
them the biggest threat to our
astronauts however are Galactic cosmic
rays they come from elsewhere in the
Milky Way the combination of their speed
and frequency makes them the most
dangerous
Galactic cosmic rays are much more
powerful than the solar cosmic rays and
they've traveled enormous distances to
mess you up
luckily our astronauts have a surprising
protector a guardian of the solar system
the Sun
as well as spitting out these high
energy solar cosmic ray particles
sun is also streaming out lots of much
lower energy particles of the solar wind
that outward moving solar wind acts as a
force field in the cosmic rays have to
work their way Upstream to get to earth
far inside this bubble
the solar wind extends 11 billion miles
around the solar system generating a
magnetic field that repels incoming
Galactic cosmic rays
it's almost like the deflector Shield of
the Starship Enterprise
so the sun's magnetic field
partially helps protect the Earth and
any astronauts from the incoming
radiation
not long ago our Voyager spacecraft made
it to that boundary between the sun's
bubble and the Galaxy and was able to
study that region and we see the
difference between inside the sun's
bubble and what's going on outside the
sun's bubble the sun has our back
billions of miles away and that's pretty
cool
the Voyager space probes discovered a
moving Battlefield
the solar wind behaves a bit like a
storm front on Earth
sometimes it advances sometimes it
Retreats when the sun's activity is the
highest it's spitting out more solar
energetic proton but those solar cosmic
rays are much less damaging than the
galactic ones so the net is a benefit
so actually ironically you might find
that astronauts it is safer to launch
missions to Mars during a period of
higher solar activity because although
you have more of the solar particle
radiation
you also get a better shielding effect
from the solar wind the sun's activity
goes through an 11-year cycle of highs
and lows the protective bubble follows
the same cycle allowing NASA to predict
the safest times to Launch
this is a thorny problem and you know we
have very smart people working on it but
we want to explore space as much as we
can but we have to lower the risk to the
astronauts as much as possible
NASA's fight against the cosmic Invaders
continues
but the biggest mystery remains what
exactly is launching the deadliest
Galactic cosmic rays
every second quadrillions of bits of
space shrapnel race towards Earth and
close to the speed of light
Galactic cosmic rays
the galactic cosmic rays are like a
rifle bullet you do not want to get hit
by one of these they are Invaders from
outside the solar system we know they're
made by something powerful within our
galaxy so the source should be easy to
detect
you'd think if one of them hits a
detector on Earth that we'd just be able
to point back in a straight line and say
it came from over there and then look is
there something else over there like a
supernova explosion that could explain
the source of this
the problem is that cosmic rays get bent
as they move by magnetic fields
the electric charge on a cosmic ray
makes it act like a little magnet
in the Milky Way is full of other
magnets if I'm a cosmic ray just
barreling through the Galaxy and I
encounter a magnetic field I'm gonna
slightly change directions maybe here
maybe there maybe up there my trajectory
is going to become scrambled
and after a few million years or so
basically all the information about
where it started has been lost it's
going in a completely random direction
for all practical purposes
but Galactic cosmic rays also have a
sidekick
one that is far less elusive
gamma rays
when a galactic cosmic ray hits a
regular atom out in space It causes this
big reaction
and emits all sorts of other particles
including gamma rays which are basically
extremely energetic photons of light
critically gamma rays don't get bent by
magnetic fields because they don't have
an electric charge so they just beeline
off in a straight line along whatever
Direction the cosmic ray was moving in
in the first place
so we can look back at where
I'm a razor coming from in the sky and
that tells us where there are a lot of
cosmic rays having collisions
[Music]
and they've led us to a prime suspect
supernovas
Supernova are some of the most powerful
explosions in the universe and so
they're ripe grounds for these highly
energetic extremely fast particles to be
created
when a giant star runs out of fuel it
can no longer support its own weight
it collapses inward
triggering a huge explosion powerful
enough to smash atoms into tiny pieces
the explosion pushes out an expanding
cloud of gas and dust the Supernova
remnant